You hear that noise?
[Silence]
That's what happened before.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Yesterday we began discussing a
narration
that is I mean this particular wording
is
from the narration of
but as we mentioned before it's been
narrated by many companions
and it is found all across the books of
Hadith and
it is something which is as prolific
and agreed upon amongst the Muslim as
and the story with that it is one of
those stories that is agreed upon across
the board amongst all of the scholars of
Islam and Muslim and this has filled the
books of hadith and taps and history etc
and it is the explanation of the
statement of Allah subhanahu
that promise that Allah gives the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam that
he will raise him up on the day of
judgment and grant him a position a very
praiseworthy position amongst humanity.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
begins this and prefaces this by saying
I am the
going to be the most honorable amongst
the people on the day of judgment.
And then he goes on to explain
and he is speaking about the great
intercession. This is something that is
specific to him. Prophets and messengers
will intercede on the day of judgment
for their
for their nations, right? And our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells us
that there are 70 nations including us.
Each messenger will intercede on behalf
of his nation and
so forth. But the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam even though he is
the last messenger and his nation is the
last of nations he will intercede on
behalf of all of the humankind and
gankind.
And so the people will be waiting on the
day of judgment for Allah to arrive and
commence judgment
of
the people and they will first come
to Adam
asking him to intercede so that Allah
would come and and begin his judgment.
And Adam will direct them to
and
will direct them to Ibraim
will say
myself. He repeats it three times
meaning only myself. only myself. I am
worried only about myself at this
moment. Go to someone else. Go to
Ibraim. Now notice when they say
you can see that
Adam before him when he it's just the
first person that comes to mind. They
just want the people to leave them be,
right? They are overwhelmed themselves.
And so
the person a person may ask well if they
all know this why didn't they just
direct people directly to Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam from Adam
from when they first went to Adam why
didn't he directly point them to the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and this is similar to the
statement of Allah
when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will ask
the people on the day will ask the
messengers
what who has answered your call
they will say we don't know why will
they say they don't know because they
are overwhelmed in the moment they are
overwhelmed in the moment
[Silence]
So they will come to Ibraim and they
will say, "Oh Ibraim, you are the
prophet of Allah and his most beloved
from the people of the earth. Intercede
on our behalf with your Lord." Do you
not see the state of our affairs? Do you
not see what we're in? What's happening
to us?
[Silence]
Jews.
And so they will mention two of his
two of his virtues. They will say,
You are the prophet of Allah and you are
his most beloved from the people of the
earth. Ahal
in the Arabic language
well
is the highest level of love
right and it's a difference amongst the
scholars and the linguists as to the
root of this word
it could be from the root word
[Silence]
So
is
it is a difference amongst the
scholars and the linguists with regards
to the etmology of this word. Some say
it's taken from which is to empty
something out and it's as if the heart
has been completely emptied of anyone
else's love except for this person. This
is your khal.
Another
another root of this word is a khal
is someone whose love has mixed itself
into the very heart and flesh of a
person.
So pickling something you know pickles
pickles olives and the things that
you pickle you put them in vinegar and
you leave them for a very long time
until they mix. This is called
in the Arabic language. It's the same
root word.
But what they all agree on
is that it is incorrect and
inconceivable
for a person to have more than one. This
is something they agree on.
They they don't say you can't say these
two people are my that's wrong. Ahal is
a spot in the heart reserved for just
one person.
And this is why it's unique for Allah
because Allah has how many?
Two. Ibraim and Muhammad sallallam.
That's specific to him.
As for the human being in the Arabic
language, only one person. And so he is
the of Allah. Allah says
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has taken
Ibraim as a and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
has mentioned this and as much he says
He says that Allah has taken me as his
just as he has taken Ibraim as his. And
he says also in the same narration and
this was days before his death.
If I were to have a khal from the people
of the earth, it would have been of but
his khal is who? Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so this is a huge huge huge honor. I
mean this is this and and this honor is
love. This is love, right? This is the
this is the greatest thing that any
human being can ever endeavor.
That's the that's the thing that makes a
person valuable. How valuable are you?
How valuable are you? How valuable am I
in the grand scheme of things in the big
picture in the life of this world and
the hereafter? What dictates my value?
How much Allah loves me. That's it. It's
not even how much I love Allah. Everyone
claims to love Allah.
Everyone claims that.
But it's actually that Allah love you
back. Very few people achieve that. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells us
how we achieve the love of Allah. It's a
process. It's not something that is
achieved overnight.
He says
for
[Silence]
and
Allah The Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says in the narration of
in the
he says and my servant continues to gain
nearness to me over time by way of
optional acts of worship until I come to
love him. This is not something that can
be forced. It takes time to build that
relationship with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Love is a very interesting thing. If I
were to say to you, what is love?
Define it. The scholars have an entire
group of words that they say attempting
to define these words only makes them
more obscure.
[Silence]
love is one of those things. Hate is one
of those things.
What does that mean? If I the more I try
to identify and define what love is, the
more obscure it becomes. I can identify
its its its symptoms, right? I can
identify
its hallmarks. But what love is, it's
trying to identify a color.
How can I explain to you what a color
is? Something you have to experience,
right? And so the human being, we all
know what love is. We don't have to
identify it. But love is something that
we can all agree on. Is something that
cannot be forced. It takes time. And the
more you try to force it, the less
likely love is to occur.
The more you try to force it, the less
likely it is to occur.
That's with human beings.
You cannot swindle
Allah's love.
You cannot gain it overnight.
It's not something that you can just
reach out and grab.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala loves first
and then he gives you his love.
And so Ibraim
he is a
love is not something you can force.
What do I mean by that? Let's say Usama
here. I want him to love me. So, I just
met him. I say, Usama,
you know I love you so much. You just
met me. This is bizarre.
Why do you love me so much? You don't
know anything about me. I'm going to
give you all kinds of presents and I
shower you with presents and I shower
you with praise and are you going to
love me or are you going to get more
suspicious of me? What? Why does this
man want this so bad? What's going on
here?
Right? It's creepy.
Love is something that you cannot force.
It takes time. It takes time to build a
relationship.
And that's why we will learn in some
other stories of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. The fastest person to love
extremely is the fastest person to hate
extremely.
We will see in certain stories of the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
people will come they'll rise up shoot
up amongst the amongst the companions
they'll shoot up
and then suddenly they'll turn into the
worst enemies of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam they'll turn into his
most bitter enemies
why
they came seeking something when they
didn't get it they have no control over
their emotions. They hate or they don't
and they love or they don't. They just
have two settings. All the way or none
at all. Right? The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam says,
"Love whoever you choose to love
moderately
because one day you may need to hate
this person."
ish.
Yeah. And whoever you hate, hate
moderately
because one day you may need to love
this person. And so it's bizarre, right,
that love and hates are so
close to each other even though they are
opposites. But this is why when you see
this phenomenon, someone comes and
overnight and they love the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and they're
giving him gifts and they're spending
all their time and and then suddenly
they turn away make hijra join his
enemies and become his worst rivals. How
can this happen?
These people are sick. This is a
disease,
right? And this is why
teaches us to be wary of people like
this.
As he tells us, you're not to love like
a little child, nor are you to hate like
a little child. that do not love a
little child and do not hate in a toxic
manner, a manner that makes you sick
from your own hatred. You hate someone
so much that you're the one that gets
sick and do not love a small child
loves, right? They can't imagine
anything else. They become obsessed.
They zero in.
So, we will pick this up again tomorrow,
inshallah.
Subhanahu
Wasam.